Blake
Woodworth so to set the stage right when
we're considering um optimization in
modern machine learning what do we see
right we have um models uh that are
based on millions and millions of
parameters and use millions and now
billions of examples to train them right
so we've gone from the now relatively
small mnist data set of the past to
being replaced by something like image
net or maybe even more recently of
tokens used to train these SP language
models and similarly the um shallow uh
uh n networks of your right have been
replaced by these very deep very dense
um networks that have led to a lot of
advances recently in um machine
learning and as I alluded to right now
we have these large language models
things like gpt3 with some 175 billion
parameters and gp4 uh with question mark
number parameters you know maybe on the
order of a trillion who knows it's a lot
uh and it's a lot to uh handle in
various aspects um not least of which is
the training um of these models right
and it's kind of uh come uh to be that
uh methods like stochastic grading
descent and its variance uh adaptive
variance momentum based variance Etc
have um proven uh critical as workhorses
of uh training and modern machine
learning um contrast right if we look
sort of Beyond uh these stochastic first
order methods to higher order methods
that is methods that rely on um
derivative information Beyond just the
first the first derivative right uh
generally under various assumptions
particularly in convex settings it's
it's most um evidence right we can get
better Oracle complexities right as the
um with sort of more derivative
information right we should expect to
sort of converge faster um but as is
usual in life right there is a catch uh
here right with the additional uh
complexity of having um these extra
derivatives right the methods start to
lose in terms of efficiency right
they're much less efficient compared to
uh firstorder methods in particular
stochastic first order methods and so uh
maybe trying to find a way to balance
these things right to move in the
direction of these higher order methods
while maintaining some semblance of
efficiency
is something we might want to uh want to
try to achieve now another facet to uh
these gains and improvements and
advances in in machine learning is
moving in the direction of distributed
optimization right so because these
models are so large and the uh data sets
are are uh depend on so many examples
right um no longer can we do all of our
training uh say on a single machine a
single GPU um we need to distribute
these um these parts of the training
over uh many machines right so uh
abstractly right we can think of having
many devices that communicate with one
another and we could uh consider
different topologies right maybe
something fully connected for how they
can communicate maybe some sort of star
topology maybe some some limited amount
of communication um and of course we can
have maybe some machines only speaking
with uh others but not some others in
the group right more specifically we see
this in the case of uh how people really
do use four or eight or 16 or 1,24
gpus sort of working in parallel and
communicating occasionally uh to be able
to train these really really normous
models uh that depend on on some
examples um and these distributed
paradigms also arise in the context of
what is known as Federated learning
right so uh here right maybe when taking
more of a privacy Centric uh view uh
maybe there is some big company like
Google or Apple or what what have you
right uh which wants to do some training
on data collected but might not want to
collect the data itself right so um an
alternative uh uh take might be to have
the training being done on clients uh uh
devices right so uh each uh uh person
maybe has a different smartphone or what
have you
and to have the training procedure take
place in a distributed fashion right
over uh their individual machines and
only send the uh parameters right the
the sort of what's being learned back to
the server aggregate there uh sort of
updates uh continue the procedure and
sort of back and forth the process goes
right so this has um even in sort of the
realm of um uh considering uh issues of
privacy these uh paradigms are are
really useful
um in all of these settings however one
of the key bottlenecks that arises is
that communicating is expensive right so
just um making sort of having all of the
devices sort of pause with what they
what they're doing and communicate with
with one another uh so that they may
update their sort of their own
parameters and continue the process is
really expensive and thus we want to try
and limit uh how often we communicate
while also balancing that against um the
um sort of optimization efficiency gains
or guarantees that we might typically
for so uh we'll take a look at our
method Federated stochastic Newton or
fedin which is a distributed stochastic
Newton method which improves upon
previous first order methods um and
under some assumptions matches some
lower bounds and again these are with
some asterisks for uh uh various
particular perameter regimes and under
the the appropriate assumption
um we also see empirically that we uh
outperform baselines particularly when
we have limited uh amounts of
communication and uh one of the sort of
uh core um computational underlying
computational aspects of of this work is
relying on sort of introducing a
stochastic heshen Vector product Oracle
right so this notion of efficient Tes
Vector products isn't isn't new it goes
back to at least the 90s if not even
earlier um and we will bring that into
our setting from a Stacy perspective and
we'll get into the details uh um more
more carefully in a bit so first I want
to sort of set the stage um for what
sort of optimization setup we will be
dealing with right so um generally right
we can uh consider some sort of
unconstrained stochastic minimization
problem right so uh it's Rd um our
function is expressed as an expectation
right for sort of Z's drawn from
distribution and we can think of the Z's
as maybe corresponding to example label
pairs or what have you but this is a
very a nice very uh General way of
expressing a stochastic optimization
problem and of course one of the first
things that you want to ask when trying
to uh uh both develop methods and and
furthermore analyze them is to ask you
know what do we know about this function
uh right is it convex which as we saw in
in the previous talk um leads to
uh lot of advantages right there there's
much more that can can be said or is it
non-convex in which you know Global
optimality guarantees will go out the
window in general um and furthermore uh
what can we say about sort of the the
the curvature or the smoothness of the
problem is it smooth right does it have
some some some nice curvage Properties
or maybe it's it's non-s smooth so you
know different um choices among the can
lead to uh different guarantees and and
and different research paths uh in this
talk we're going to focus on the convex
setting and smooth uh setting right so
convex and smooth will will be um key to
to this work though of course we can
maybe for for other things consider uh
Al Alternatives here so again we have
now unconstrained convex is the
qualifier here stochastic minimization
problem uh and as I mentioned right
we're going to assume smoothness more
specific
uh we say that our function is H smooth
uh if for all X and Y the grad the
difference or the norm of the difference
of the gradients at X and Y is bounded
by H times the norm difference of X and
Y think of it as just a lip condition
lipit continuity condition on the the
gradient we'll also make a bounded
minimizer assumption right this really
just kind of means that the the uh
solution isn't too far away and of
course you should maybe expect to depend
on how far away the solution is from say
where you start and maybe where you
start uh could by default be at the at
the origin right so we'll parameterize
that by capital B and also as is typical
in uh understanding stochastic gradient
methods we're going to assume uh some
uniformly bounded gradient variance
right so we'll let Sigma um Sig square
balance the the the
variance um I should also point out that
um uh when dealing in a distributed
setting there are a couple of uh
different um uh considerations we'll be
working in what is known as the
homogeneous distributed setting which
means that every machine has access to
the same underlying uh distribution of
data uh in contrast there are uh
settings known as the the heterogeneous
setting uh whereby each machine has
access to a different underlying
distribution of the data uh and while we
don't consider this it's certainly
garnered much interest here are just a
very non-exhaustive list of papers that
have work worked in in that realm and
certainly we can imagine maybe the
Federated learning setting um the
importance of handling the case where
devices data are generated you know in
general uh uh by different distributions
right I also want to note that we work
in the stochastic or sort of the one
pass or streaming setting uh and this is
in contrast with the batch or the RM
setting which uh considers problems of
some finite some form right so we really
are going to consider a a a sort of a
purely stochastic minimization problem
where we sort of only get to access um
where we'll sort of Define some sort of
stochastic access to information about
the
function um it's also important not only
to uh sort of set up what the function
looks like and sort of how these
distributions are formed but also what
is the um format of the or the structure
of the communication uh so we will
consider what's known as the
intermittent communication setting um
basically we're going to have M machines
uh sort of working in
parallel and these M machines will get
to uh do K iterations of something so
we'll need to specify what that
something is but we want to imagine sort
of K uh operations that take place and
ideally sort of for all the machines
those K operations will sort of finish
roughly at the same time so we should
expect those operations to be comparable
in terms of their efficiency uh and
after these K iterations we will sort of
communicate right uh the communication
will take place uh the machines will
sort of update their uh information
based on information being informed from
others and this process uh repeats uh
for some R rounds of communication this
results in some uh K times R total
parallel runtime right so sort of the
the total number of uh um operations
taking place for any given machine is
something like you know K * R and of
course that itself is taking place over
in machines in in parallel now in this
framework uh a very uh a natural thing
to do would be to draw on what we know
uh works well in a sequential setting
right so this brings us to one uh uh uh
one method that fits into this
distributed framework known as local SGD
and it's really quite quite natural
quite simple although maybe not so
simple to analyze it turns out but the
idea is um for each machine basically
going to have uh every iteration be a
single step of um of stochastic Rance
right of SGD with respect to its local
parameters so if we focus um for a
minute on machine lowercase M right and
we have whatever it's iterate is on this
this machine and again we're kind of
putting on blinders and ignoring the
other machines for now uh we can uh sort
of sample some some Z from Z rather from
the distribution take the gradients at
zot for for it's the parameters on this
machine take a uh a step of SGD with
some uh step size Ada update our
parameter on machine M take another step
update uh to the parameter exit M2 and
so on and so forth we do this for all of
the machines in parallel and so it
amounts effectively to M parallel runs
of of
SGD um and uh after all the machines
have have finished uh they take the
final it they communicate to them they
are averaged sent back to the machines
and this averaged iterate is used as the
starting point for the next for the next
TR um and one kind of nice observation
here is that local SGD or maybe even its
accelerated variance um it's a method
that's very well suited for optimizing
quadratics in particular and uh
essentially the reason boils down to um
because because the um gradient of the
quadratic is is is linear there's some
uh sort of exchange uh UHS of like
expectation that happens in the the uh
uh deeper parts of the analysis uh but
you know at a high level we can just
sort of take that this type of method
for whatever reason works really really
well for quadratic minimization
problems so what about going Beyond
these stochastic first order methods and
again this brings us back to um what I
alluded to in in the a talk right so uh
a classic method for uh uh introducing
uh second order information is known as
New right so we instead of taking a a
step sort of purely in the direction of
the gradient we're going to redirect it
based on the Hess information right this
MRI we invert the Hess multiply by the
gradient H take our step and continue
and under various assumptions this is
known to converge uh fast if you're
close enough to the minimizer under
again the appropriate assumptions you
can converge very very fast um but uh
even in um these uh so deterministic
settings it's going to be expensive to
compute the hessen and invert the hessen
and only more so in a uh stochastic
setting right uh you what is it U um how
does one without just sort of some um
pure Oracle access right how do you get
uh the full uh Hess and let alone the
cost that was taken to invert it and so
what we want to ask right is whether
there's a a better and ideally some
parallel way to uh Implement something
maybe like this um note that again quite
quite simply an alternative view of of
Newton's method is simply to to think
about um each step as being the
minimization of some quadratic sub
problem right so some model um uh some
second tail expansion uh model around XT
uh is our function Q ofx um and uh uh
again going back to our observation that
local SD Works quadratics here's here's
an a particular quadratics right sort of
defined locally for our function can we
use local SGD on quadratic problems of
this form right um H one thing to note
is that the gradient of this sub problem
is uh something like the hessen times
some Vector plus a uh plus the gradient
at XT right so um if we have some
stochastic um gradient uh access Oracle
access for our function f then maybe we
could use that to get you know this part
of of this gradient of q but of course
that's not sufficient right U uh to sort
of fully capture this um uh gr of Q
right we might need some additional
Oracle access to get uh to get at this H
Vector product comp right um now that
might seem uh
a bit of complication right because this
session is some D byd Matrix let should
take D squ time to sort of write and
then multiply by Vector again some d
square time but it turns out that um uh
for problems with sufficient structure
that we can actually do this quite a bit
more efficiently I like to point this
out in the context of uh generalized uh
linear
models specifically things like logistic
regression where they can be uh computed
in time basically proportional to the
same cost of computing a stochastic
gradient uh how do we see this if you um
take a given sample in one of these
generalized linear models the Hess is
rank one so we can just kind of shift
the product to an inner product get a
scaler and then multiply it by a vector
so this is kind of a proof of concept of
of why this might be be possible but it
sounds out that that's this advantage
that one can do a HH Vector product in
linear time essentially you sort of
proportional to the cost of Comm
stochastic gradient uh actually it holds
also for for neural networks right
basically as long as essentially if
there's enough sort of structure to the
to the function we can do these this
type of operation rather efficiently um
so this uh kind of naturally leads us to
consider um some additional or Oracle
model right so we've already uh um sort
of seen something like the standard
stochastic gradient Oracle right this is
some Oracle that will output some some
variable such that it it an unbiased
estimator of the true gradient and we
you know need to have some standard
bound variance so why not also consider
introducing some stochastic analog of a
hessen vector product Oracle right so
similarly right we might want to have um
some uh Oracle that would give us a
random variable uh whose that would be
an unbiased estimator of the hessen at
some point x times the vector v so this
is uh analogous to this compon it and
similarly we want to have or we sort of
expect to need some kind of bound on the
variance of the estimator and Technical
notes though maybe not so unexpected is
that we have both our roow parameter for
the variance uh but we also have sort of
reason needs a dependence on the norm of
our Vector our vector
v so that's one uh uh aspect right we we
can try to bring additional Oracle
access into the model and see where that
leads us um but we might also want to to
consider um uh additional um
restrictions on on the function that are
still relevant or that still you provide
relevance to to things that that we care
about um which leads uh to some notion
of uh quasi self-concordance right or QC
condition um there's been much recent
interest uh and it's a really nice idea
that has led to a lot of follow-up work
uh but the idea is we have some beta
quasi self-importance condition
which um is kind of like the self
concordance conditions for those who are
familiar with that right some relation
between the third derivative and a
second derivative the main difference is
we don't have a three Hales power on
this Hess component on the right hand
side in a sense the extra uh like half
power gets shifted in a sense from a
local notion of regularity to a more
typical ukian notion of of of regularity
right um uh for those uh uh for for whom
this is maybe less clear basically we
can think of this as some additional
regularity condition analogous to or
something kind of like smoothness or
high order smoothness right that sort of
just relates some derivatives particular
way uh its implications um are are much
clearer so it turns out that uh all
kinds of of nice uh functions and
important functions me to this condition
such as logistic aggression softmax
regularized LP regression um and not
only uh uh does it is it met by uh
problems of interest but it turns out
that um uh this condition uh with this
condition we can uh get fast convergence
by minimizing not too many um or by
solving rather not too many constrain
quadratic minimization problems right so
we have a quadratic constraint to some
some radius of of the um of the variable
right and um this will we can be shown
that this this canes fast right uh so
taking these pieces and putting them all
together right the main idea of our
method fed us in will be to uh at every
iteration right solve some constrained
quadratic minimization problem and uh
because we saw earlier the advantage of
local SGD for these unconstrained
problems right we we need to kind of
take one more step and break down this
constrained problem into a sequence of
not too many uh unconstrained quadratic
problems it really sort of boils down to
a typical
kind of like a trust region method right
and for each of these unconstrained sub
problems do exactly that we're going to
run local SGD on this uh sub problem
with a single round of communication
right so that's the kind of the
interesting thing not only is local
SGD well suited to quadratics but it's
well suited to quadratics with any
number of rounds of communication
because we want to communicate as little
as possible we might as well sort of
only take a single a single round right
just communicate right at the very
end um and
uh uh we will need not only the
stochastic gradient but also this extra
hash Vector product Oracle but we
already sort of Saw uh what that what
that should look like um putting all of
these pieces together uh brings us to
the main theorem of the work uh
basically uh if our function um you know
is convex smooth reasonably conditioned
uh has bounded minimizer and our our
algorithm has access to uh both of these
set of oracles right some stochastic
gradient and a stochastic Oracle then we
get some kind of complicated balance
with a lot of dependence on parameters
that that I've defined but that is maybe
not so easy to understand right we have
some exponentially decaying terms here
uh we have some noise terms one with
respect to the gradient noise one with
respect to theic noise uh and then this
term has no noise dependence and this
kind of feels a little bit like the the
bias or the sort of the gradient descent
term if there were no noise right so um
it looks kind of reasonable and yet it's
still a bit difficult to to interpret so
we'll try to simplify things a little
bit in comparing with previous methods
so uh one of the previous best methods
is fedac um which is like an accelerated
variant of Federate averaging or local
SD um it's a bit difficult to directly
compare because of the different
assumption sets right they consider some
third order smoothness we consider the
QSC condition right it's a little bit
apples oranges so we tried to level the
playing field by uh introducing some
natural scaling parameter the details of
which are not so important basically
suffice you to say it's an you know an
attempt to again level the playing field
and um make uh sort of more direct
comparison uh between these methods uh
when we sort of introduce and account
for this parameter scaling what we find
is that um we get a rate for fedc that
looks like this and rate for fet looks
like this and you modulo the uh
difference of the power of D&B in the
den numerator right we have sort of a
trade-off in the power of K and R so K
to the thir R to the 43 or fedac versus
a root k r for FSN um and sort of if we
take one more step we can see by sort of
comparing parameters that when R is uh
um upper bounded by root K Over DB DB
that is when the um uh number rounds of
communication is is small right when we
have a limited am of communication uh
then uh our method is able to sort of
improve upon the rate of of fedac um
there is also uh a rough attempt to
compare with with lower bounds we have
some work that has lower bounds under
this QSC condition um the main catch is
that there the Oracle access is with
respect to uh stochastic gradient rather
than stochastic gradients and stochastic
has VOR products so again it's a little
bit difficult to directly compare um
maybe there's some sense in which uh
those can uh be almost interchangeable
certainly this happens in the
deterministic setting but those issues
aside right if we want to try and you
know as a very very coarse comparison
get a sense of what happens you know in
this natural parameter setting uh when
sort of DB is like a one and when we
have limited communication then we get
something that matches is the lower
bound so again there are are many
caveats here um the the clarification of
which would be uh um uh again something
very interesting for for future work um
empirically too we see that our method
uh does quite well um these uh plots um
are both for some fixed parallel runtime
so this means that we've sort of fixed T
parallel runtime T to be 100 uh that
means that 100 steps are being taken
place and the uh uh x-axis shows the
number of communication rounds so the
rightmost um points of both of these
plots are uh when we allow 100 rounds of
communication so we communicate every
single step um and not surprisingly
right the methods tend to do better as
we get to communicate more often right
um so all the methods kind of have that
tendency to to do better um the question
is um how do uh the methods do uh when
we have less communication right right
so the rightand most uh plot or points
are when we only communicates five times
right sort of 20 steps in between indeed
we see that as the number as the amount
of communication decreases we uh have
sort of an improvements an improved gap
between our plots and sort of pink and
red compared to um standard based lines
methods like fedac um local SGD a Minash
SGD I should note that this is for a
more empirically inclined variant which
we call fetus and light but the spirit
is the same so to break down the problem
to appropriate procept problems and
minimize those uh some open problems uh
as I mentioned uh can we extend the
lower bound uh uh uh results that we
have in terms of sastic gradiant to
account for stochastic hctor products
now it might not seem such a big deal
right because we know in a deterministic
setting hctor products and uh gradients
are kind of roughly equivalent or they
can sort of be transformed from one to
the other but in a stochastic setting
it's a bit more subtle so there might be
some hope for some interesting results
results there and this will course a
little complicate what we got complement
what we have another U um point that
might have Arisen in the minds of some
right is asking whether we can use an
accelerated variance right something
like local acsa rather than local sud as
the main parallel solver for for
quadratics there are some technical
issues in the analysis that that seem to
arise from a a naive attempt um but
maybe there's something that can be done
there and of course uh I'm also
interested in considering other uh uh
Notions of acceleration something like
montos fighter type acceleration right
something on the outside of uh these
methods that use these quadratic um sub
problems um and of course we can go the
other way around right we can ask uh
whether local SGD or fedc could be um
analyzed under under this QSC condition
right that doesn't seem to be fully
exposed there so in conclusion right we
we've uh seen in this talk a distributed
stochastic nant type method uh for uh
optimizing QSC objectives um our methods
uh uh at the heart of our method is L
leveraging nice quadratic structure of
the sub problem which can be taken um
which can be used by um certain parallel
methods um we get some improvements uh
uh uh both empirically and uh um in
terms of convergence guarantees over
previous first order methods while
maintaining a similar computational cost
and again empirically uh we see our um
improvements most pronounced in the loow
communication regime thank
you any questions
for very nice talk so I have a few
questions about the convergence rate can
you tell us what are the parameters like
B and T and K in that slide yeah uh yes
yes yes yes so um
I they have to do with the uh basically
the setup of the problem so uh they kind
of show up a little bit throughout the
talk right so here's the sigma and the
row those have to do with the uh
variance of the oracles uh there's the
beta for the quad coordinance right so
the again some some the structure of the
curvature of the of the problem um and
then the other key ones are
back oh so in our uh communication setup
right we have our M machines our K
iterations sort of between the
communication and the r rounds of
communication so this gives us the the
parallel runtime so MK and R are really
uh um uh parameters of the distributed
uh framework like the the setup and then
the final parameters are uh um uh from
our basic assumption right so we're
going to have our H is our smoothness B
is the bound on the minimizer this
minimizer and again we have our our
Sigma uh as the variance Bound for the
gradients I think that covered uh all of
them okay so more like m is like mini
batch uh and yes so um I didn't discuss
mini batch SGD but you certainly could
um uh recover a parallel mini batch SD
from this framewor
in particular right what you would
expect to have is a mini batch size like
an like if you were to sort of flip
things around from the local SGD view to
the mini batch view the mini batch size
the Natural Choice of the mini batch
size would be M times K right basically
the idea there would be you fix you've
communicated you have every machine has
the same starting iterates uh take a k
times take stochastic gradients from
that same iterates don't step anywhere
just take them by the same iterance to
accumulate them store them right do that
over all in machines and then
communicate all of those right so that
at the end sort of when you communicate
you would have a mini batch of size M *
K and that leads to different
convergence rates and it's a bit it's a
subtle to to compare them but it is
important to to compare
them so do you have a separate
complexity Bound for like gradient and
Matrix Vector modlic like ah yes so we
don't have a separate um lower bound to
to get a sense of how much how what
advantage sort of this can can provide
over just the stochastic gradient
certainly I find it advantageous to uh
uh use it in the context of sort of
quadratic sub problems right that's sort
of the the the through line um I should
note that um again in a deterministic
setting there's very essentially no
difference between a gradient and a
deterministic gradient and a
deterministic h product in the
stochastic setting it's a bit more
subtle about whether or not you allow
for sampling uh uh at like the same
point more than once if you require
something that's kind of purely
stochastic you have to always sample
somewhere else it's kind of at the whims
of the Oracle uh then this can lead to a
divide between what a stochastic H
Vector product and a stochastic gradient
Oracle can do in some other context in
particular in the context of non-convex
optimization for reaching stationary
points uh so we can talk about that
offline if you like to but there's some
very very interesting subtleties here
about the uh Power of these oracles
great thank
you any other
questions great talk I was just
interested in uh the part where we had
the communication you um how do you guys
think about like the relation between
time because let's say you just have
like a basic the first like SVD that's
running versus this one um when you have
the communication kind of abstracts away
the sense of time from and in some of
them like you have the X with a t so how
do you guys think about that that's an
excellent question um so we we
absolutely do abstract it away and we
just assume that you know everyone
finishes roughly about the same time and
of course the reality W won't sort of
reflect that um so one can account for
time and delays and and this has been
done and sort of it's continuing to be
done in in other works for asking things
like you know maybe you have one holdout
machine that's just taking forever do
you cut it off at some point do you
ignore it um what happens if there's
some staggering etc etc and and what you
can do is um sort of try to uh you know
account for this or parameterize this or
introduce parameters that reflect to
this and analyze under those settings so
um with additional complications that uh
uh reflect reality and arise in in
realistic situations come models that
try to you know model those extra
complications so we don't do that right
we we abstract that away but there is a
a lot of work that does try to get into
the those details and more for
passion all right so let's thank
Brian and we'll take a short break until